the pasok river dividing north and south manila
american tanks and tank destroyers on the north
bank of the river fire at last remaining [ __
] strongholds in the southern part of the city
155-millimeter howitzer x' lob shells across
the river to blast the walls of Intramuros and
adjacent buildings 240 millimeter guns of the 540
for field artillery firing point-blank against the
ancient walls [ __ ] defensive positions are soft
enough for territory to a crossing of the river
machine guns firing at [ __ ] emplacements
in the Letran man post office buildings
under a protective barrage of artillery mortar
machine gun and rifle fire troops of the 3rd
battalion 120 9th infantry 37th division
crossed the Pasig River and assault boats
landing on the southern bank the troops pan
out to advance on the walled city where the
Japs are dug in for a last stand public buildings
adjacent to Intramuros are strongly fortified with
pillboxes of machine-gun nests our troops pour
through a breach in the northeast section of
the wall entry into Intramuros is made 23rd
february by elements of the 37th division
tnt charges for blowing up and ceiling
the walls underground tunnel system
troops edged forward picking off jeff snipers with
closed rifle fire a [ __ ] pillbox
at the base of the wall is destroyed
155 millimeter howitzers blast-jet pulled
up in the Legislative Agricultural and
Finance buildings troops of B Company
148 regiment from their positions in
the record city hall and bats
upon the Legislative Building
flamethrowers burnout [ __ ]
fortifications under the wall more
than 1500 of the enemy mostly naval personnel
were annihilated in the Intramuros fighting
floor by floor and room by room fighting
rages within the buildings of the walled
city our advance is held up by Japs fighting from
strong points in the corridors and on portraits
Infantryman close in on the remaining jacks the
last pocket of enemy resistance inside intramuros
is smashed 24th february three weeks after the
entry of american troops into the Philippine
capital Medical Corps troops following up the
infantry attack on Intramuros arrive on the
south bank of the Pasig River Filipino is killed
in the intensive artillery fire by the Japs the
enemy tortured and murdered civilians refusing
to allow them safe passage out of the walled city
we can shell-shocked after [ __ ] torture this
st. Augustine priest has given food by the nuns
of the Santa Clara sisterhood Chinese and Filipino
Red Cross workers carry out wounded Filipinos from
the santo domingo church where over 500 people
sought shelter from american and jeff gun fire
evacuation Intramuros away transportation
across the Pasig River to the northern
sections of Manila these people have been under
almost continuous artillery barrage for 10 days
the japs allowed them a minimum of food and
water many are wounded and shell-shocked
General Douglas MacArthur and Serio's mania
president of the Philippine Commonwealth
government arrived at the gates of malecon yon
palace within earshot to the fighting which still
rages in the remaining enemy health buildings of
South Manila a simple ceremony is held to mark the
rebirth of the Philippine Commonwealth government
speaking over the radio networks and before an
audience which packed the state reception room of
the palace General MacArthur bitterly denounced
the Japanese for their wanton destruction of
Filipino life and property and said that the
Filipino Commonwealth was now at liberty to
pursue its destiny in the family of Nations
president serious mania in his speech stresses
the many problems of reconstruction facing the
nation and holds forth the possibility of the
Philippines soon attaining complete independence
he urges his countrymen to forget petty political
differences and to obey the rule of law justice
and reason General MacArthur greets mrs. Oz mania
leaving the palace General MacArthur salutes a
Filipino guard of honor he drives through the
gates into the city of which he helped liberate
and which in his own words has regained
its rightful place as a symbol of democracy